as one of the teen titans most memorable
enemies a Trigon has shown up to Menace
nearly every incarnation of the team but
what is it that makes this demon so
memorable join us as we dive into the
forbidden history of Ravens fearsome
father and all the havoc he has wreaked
Trigon unstoppable avatar of evil and
bringer of doom but GAD is immortal life
as a mistake on the part of the good
guys
centuries ago a band of humans who were
wary of human suffering created a Haven
between dimensions the place that would
become Azeroth it was paradise built by
human hands led by a czar a visionary
mystic the pacifists of Azeroth decided
to cement their utopia by purging it of
all evil at first they seemed to have
succeeded in this monumental task but
the dark energy began to coalesce into
something altogether darker ages past
until a sect on a doomed and distant
planet summoned the dark spirit in a
last-ditch attempt to survive all the
castes of energy inhabited a woman of
the order and nine months later
Trigon was born his first act was to
slaughter his mother and her compatriots
which was the beginning of a long and
bloody career of conquest like many
comic characters Trigon doesn't have one
singular origin the new 52 a line wide
reboot of the DC universes characters
and continuity gave Trigon an alternate
origin rooted and even more potent forms
of evil
according to Teen Titans issue 23.1 a
villain month special where the bad guy
stepped into the spotlight
Trigon was created through the folly of
a trio of alien beings known as the
divine acting as interstellar
peacekeepers they discovered a world
that thought was cleansed of wickedness
had devolved into brutal chaos after
finding the man responsible the divine
attempted to quarantine him by feeding
him to the heart of darkness an
inescapable abyss to which they
consigned all evil but the culprit was a
juvenile Trigon and his power was too
great instead of being consumed by the
heart he consumed it thus devouring the
millions of wicked souls a divine a
place within it flooded with power
Trigon killed the divine and resolved to
blanket the universe in his evil but he
quickly found that he couldn't escape a
barrier the diviner directed and dawn
said he began to transport female
humanoids his way to be
preg nated and spreaders and holy soul
throughout the cosmos
while Ravens mother Ella had originally
been fooled by a mystical disguise she
eventually learned the truth of her
daughter's parentage the demon Trigon
was Ravens father those someone Azeroth
wary of Raven given her domestic
ancestry she was allowed to grow learn
and master her powers within the
sanctity of its borders but not even an
interdimensional Eden could shelter
Raven for long nor keep a regnant of her
father's thirst for power terrified of
what he might unleash upon an
unsuspecting populace Raven travelled to
earth and asked the Justice League for
aid when she was turned away she had no
choice but to gather a team of heroes on
her own the lineup that would become the
new Teen Titans in this way Trigon
planted the seed of his own destruction
fear of him didn't keep Raven quiet
pliable or cowed it empowered her to
defy him regardless of the consequences
she refused to further her father's
destructive agenda refused to accept the
Justice League's cold shoulder and
finally refused to give in to the
Armageddon that Trigon briefly brought
to the earth
Trigon might've thought fathering
half-demon children would seal his
eventual victory but he didn't count on
that human halves winning out
Ravin gains her powers to her demonic
parentage but it was her ability to love
find fellowship and work alongside her
friends that truly mattered in the fight
against her father with trigons level of
hellish power to deal with it makes
sense to ask are the Teen Titans finally
managed to bring down the terror of a
thousand worlds
well it wasn't easy an initial attempt
at combined all of the Titans powers
Arella sympathic abilities and an
interdimensional portal puts him away
for a while
but it didn't destroy him entirely
Trigon have a patient bided his time
ruminating upon the abilities of Ravens
new team and how we might counter them
steadily growing in power until he was
able to break free of his bonds in one
terrifying campaign of violence Trigon
laid siege to Azeroth murdering its
inhabitants and corrupted Ravens soul
entirely but the souls of Azeroth hadn't
dissolved into the ether being a
magically powerful they dwelt within the
rings of azar holy relics worn by Raven
in a complex plan that the Titans were
taken over by Trigon zville and murdered
Raven a terrible act that nevertheless
allowed the souls of Azeroth to use her
as a channel Trigon was implanted with
pure as a Ratheon lights and his soul
was just incorporates it and his body
torn apart with Trigon seemingly
vanquished Raven came back to life and
the world returned to normal good had
one but not without a bat so a few of
the titans would ever be able to forget
Raven is of course trigons most famous
child but the legendary body made sure
to have far more than one kid to choose
from when it came to his nefarious plans
hundreds of trigons offspring populate
the DC Universe many of them possibly
even ignorant of their heritage
Raven wasn't so lucky and neither were
the boys who became known as the sons of
Trigon introduced in 2008 Titans issue
three there were originally six members
of the group called the sons of Trigon
conceived around the same time Raven was
they were intended to embody the seven
deadly sins with Raven as a seventh
representing pride Jessie jared and
jacob MV wat and lust respectively
emerged as the leaders of the heinous
septet and they used Raven as a portal
to where their weakened father slumbered
and yet they didn't raise him as you
might expect instead - they stole away
his power for themselves and act so evil
that
we made their fearsome father smile they
were of course eventually defeated by
Raven and the Titans but the idea of
Raven having siblings wasn't intriguing
enough notion that after the new 52
reboot it was reintroduced in 2013 in
the pages of the Phantom Stranger issued
to nowadays Raven has three brothers
named belly ole Bruce Gough and Suge
what's haven't they might wreak remains
to be seen but it's a pretty safe bet
for readers to assume it will be
terrible when it arrives
initially the new 52 meant afresh
tougher Raven as a typical girl named
Rachel ruff but try Khan's daughter
never gets a reprieve for long and the
Phantom Stranger ultimately delivered
her back into the arms of her father
after a stretch of time in the under
realms where even reimburses her
father's blackbird of terror keen to
conquer the world on his behalf
Trigon had in fact discovered a certain
respect for his daughter over the course
of their time together naming her as his
favorite child and seeking to use her as
a spearhead for future attacks on earth
naturally Raven turned against him saved
the world alongside the Titans and sent
Trigon back to where he came from
she hadn't ever truly been his creature
instead she'd merely become an
impeccable actress even with that though
trigons favoritism was striking during
this period and he even desired to
install Raven upon the throne as Trigon
detailed while torturing his other three
children
Ravens knowledge of love compassion and
justice would he believed make her a
conqueror he himself couldn't become
it's a twisted sort of respect to be
certain and still largely self-serving
but for a time Trigon saw his daughter
as greater than himself if only in one
crucial aspect Trigon is an all-star
villain the source of world shattering
powerhouse whose appearances require
entire storylines worth of buildup
execution and resolution his as an evil
that extends beyond his own stories
however to the point of creating
entirely separate bad guys Simon an
enormous leap hour for psychic is the
most famous example of trigons
prodigious once a physicist seeking to
place new trails and dimensional
exploration he got quite a bit more than
he bargained for when he accidentally
breached trigons realm seizing this rare
opportunity
Trigon imbued the hapless scientist with
devastating mental abilities twisted him
towards his own desire
conquer the earth and presumably told
him to start spelling his name with a
silent P Simon sets out to further
trigons mission join the fearsome five
and began a long and ugly career of
brutality manipulation and violence
however he didn't actually end up doing
much to carry out trigons plans and
after a stint of banishment he appeared
to have been forgotten by His Dark
Master and fortunately that didn't stop
Simon from using his powers for evil and
if anything had been freed to create as
much panic and mayhem as he liked
following no agenda but his own desire
to inflict cruelty Simon stands at the
monument to trigons malice and power a
decent member of society left shattered
and rotten by a passing glance from
world-shaking evil but Trigon started
though the Joker ended when most of DC's
villains were trapped on another planet
Simon annoyed the Clown Prince of climes
so much that he wound up finding out why
it's a bad idea to keep your brain
inside a glass dome one of the best
things about superhero comics as a
multiple choice approach to storytelling
so it goes with Trigon perhaps his most
unique form is that of - Trigon a
villain of the DC bombshells series
within the bombshells universe Trigon
was a German Mountain spirit whose
liaison with a human woman led to Raven
here Raven grew up in a small alpine
village instructed by her grandfather
and the control of her powers until the
Joker's daughter appended a tranquil
life eventually Raven rediscovered her
father working for dark masters but this
wasn't the aimless evil of trigons past
in this story
Trigon felt utterly untethered when
Ravens mother died so he gave up on
goodness to join the dastardly general
Faora and so far you're a threatened
Ravens life
Trigon fell defending his daughter who
buried him beneath a tree and web for
the father she'd never known as well as
she would have liked it was a very
different Trigon indeed and all the more
affecting for it these days most kids
know the Teen Titans from Teen Titans go
where Robin Starfire Beast Boy Raven and
cyborg spend more time scarfing burritos
and getting into wacky scrapes involving
waffles than they do crime fighting
first off the wall as a cartoon is
however it digs deeply into DC's vast
and complex history including of course
Trigon and all the Terra he's visited
upon the Titans but like so many
and characters who have made an
appearance on Teen Titans go this
cartoon version of Trigon is rather
different instead of his usual look you
know capes ragged loincloths giant
demonic antlers he wears sweater vests
slacks and neckties and sure yes he
subscribed as a master of the dark
destroyer of dimensions in slaver of
civilizations but well he does make sure
to always spend Thanksgiving with his
daughter and when demon's prom rolls
around he nominates Raven for prom queen
and he does spend Father's Day leaping
through treasured photos of his baby
girl Trigon is a bad guy in Teen Titans
go but that doesn't necessarily mean
he's a bad dad he might want to rule the
earth but he also wants what's best for
his precious daughter no matter how
embarrassed that my maker
I'm so proud the only thing left to do
is kill all your friends check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]